elle fournit elle fournit pardon en
denrées alimentaires des associations
caritatives comme la Croix-Rouge qui
elle-même les redistribue au plus
démunis problèmes la Banque alimentaire
de Touraine est confrontée à une chute
drastique de ses dons moins 12%. alors
en attendant la grande collecte de mai
bien elle est obligée d'acheter des
produits une première les explications
de Sarah gros
la Banque alimentaire de Touraine n'est
pas épargnée par l'inflation en raison
d'une baisse de dons quotidien estimée à
12%, elle doit pour la première fois
acheter des produits pour compléter ses
stocks on sent vraiment que les grandes
surfaces et les industriels font
attention à réduire les gaspillages on
va dire au niveau des productions au
niveau des ventes et du coup adopte de
nouvelles politiques de gestion des
stocks et ça amène à une réduction des
des dons qu'on reçoit une part
d'approvisionnement minime puisqu'elle
représente environ 2% des stocks mais
reste nécessaire pour pallier
l'inflation le total de la commande
qu'on a reçu il y avait du il y a du
sucre il y a des sauces tomates
9998 euros d'achat ont été dépensés pour
combler le manque de dons mais aussi
l'augmentation des bénéficiaires une
hausse estimée à 12% selon le président
de l'association
nous avions toujours eu des demandeurs
d'emploi mais à nouveau profil c'est
prononcé ce sont des travailleurs et
travailleurs qui ont un salaire qui
travaille et qui sont en situation
précarité alimentaire les personnes
isolées aussi les personnes seules les
retraités les étudiants et les familles
monoparentales
la Banque Alimentaire souhaite optimiser
ses chances en étant présentes dans plus
de magasins pour la collecte de
printemps qui se tiendra sur deux jours
et demi du 12 au 14 mai
pour